pornography is a public health crisis
that is ruining lives do you think that
that is true I am living proof this year
the Republican Party added a new point
to its platform saying that pornography
is a public health crisis and it has
ruined millions of lives so we're here
at the convention to talk to the
Republicans about what they think of
that I agree with that sentiment yes do
you think that's an appropriate thing
for a political party to be focusing on
interferes with the healthy relationship
that a man should have with a woman
pornography is a disgusting Bane on our
civilization it's nothing different than
adultery do you think that pornography
is a public health crisis that needs to
be stopped
absolutely I don't know why that would
be in the platform I think there are too
many laws we're a free country you want
to look at for an ography go for it as
long as it's not child pornography I
think they're closeted born watchers
that's what I think I have a real
problem with the Republican Party trying
to get into our bedroom don't tell me
who to sleep with don't tell me what a
marriage platform says who even read
this there are certain social issues I
hear about the porn you're either gonna
look at me I I think it's there's not
really a place board we have such bigger
issues to focus on have you ever watched
pornography I'm gonna take the Fifth
Amendment on
it's outlawed you don't think that that
is not very at odds with limited
government principles there might be a
little bit of a discussion there if
we're gonna take God's Word and throw in
the trash we're gonna have society full
of trash that if you watch too much porn
ography you might go blind so I just
wear glasses